نحن بنايتنا غاصه غوص كل ما وصل على
الطابق الاول انفجروا الشبابيك طلعوا
العلامه نقاصه الطابق الثاني كذلك الامر
غاصب للطابق الثالث والنصف كمان نحن طلعنا
كسرنا الابواب وكسرنا الحيطان وطلعناه
والحمد لله رب العالمين
وفي كثير اعداد ماتت يعني الحمد لله نحن
من الناجين انا وخمس اطفال كان عندك خمس
اطفال يعني كيف كيف كانت عم تغوص يعني
الارتجاج مع عم تتخلوا على الحيطان وعم
تتخلوا على الشبابيك ونحن عم نرقد عم ضب
هالاولاد ما عاد نعرف منين نطلع راح بيت
الدرج ما شفنا نحن حالنا نزلنا من بيت
الجيران على الشارع مباشر نحن في الطابق
الثالث
بفضل الله الحمد لله على السلامه هلا
انتوا قاعدين هون بهاي الخيمه بهاي الخيمه
تسع اشخاص انا وعائلتي وخمس اولاد وفي
عندي حرمه وبنتها كمان عندي هن الله
يعطيكم العافيه انا بدي اسالك هلا كيف
وضعكم هلا
بالخيام هل الوضع جيد هل في مساعدات عم
توصلكم بشكل دائم مواد تدفئه مواد تدفئه
وسط امبارح على الصوبه ولكن اعطونا
اسفنجتين وبطانيات والخامات ضيقه كتير
صغيره كتير يعني ما بتكفينا بتقول لي تسعه
تسعه اشخاص ايه تسعه اشخاص تخيل انه هاي
المعدات مو كافيه طبعا مو كافيه ما بتكفي
تدبير يعني تدبير امر يعني مو اكثر الحاله
النظافه ما في
طيب هلا حضرتك يعني حضرتك موجود بالخيمه
هلا صار لكم قديش صار لي من يوم الزلزال
بعد بيومين استلمنا الخملها وقبل ما
تستلموا الخيمه نمنع الرصيف وكان في تلج
وشغلنا نار والحمد لله ضمينا للاطفال هيك
يعني كانت صعبه كتير كتير
الحمد لله على سلامتكم انا ما رح طول كتير
بس انا بدي اسالك اخر شيء يعني انت حاليا
موجود بالخدمه انت برايك شو المطلوب هلا
لحتى
تستعيد وعافيتكم يعني بشكل صحيح وترجعوا
لحياتكم الطبيعيه برايك انت شو شو الحل او
شو هو المطلوب من ان كان من الحكومه
التركيه او حتى من المنظمات عم تشتغل
وبتساعد او الدول عم تبعت مساعدات نحن
المطلوب يعني هل الوضع هذا ما راح يستمر
مدينه مدمره بالكامل بالكامل 90% او
بالكامل
الافضل يعني نعني براينا الحل يكون الامه
المتحده تشيل القسم من السوريين او عدد
كبير من السوريين هون بكون ساعدت تركيا
بمعاناته بتخف العبء عن تركيا واذا امم
متحده شالت قسم من اللاجئين او عدد كبير
من اللاجئين بخفوا الحمل عن تركيا الوضع
شوي يعني بصير اسهل يعني كل واحد بيحمل
كتف عن الثاني
شكرا شكرا جزيلا لالك ونتمنى المعاناه ما
تستمر شكرا يعني كما تابعنا المعاناه
الكبيره حقيقه المدينه شبه مدمره بالكامل
ولذلك حجم المعاناه كبير في مدينه اصلاحيه